[Music]
this is where
see i have a second character now we're
about to get you a second
[Music]
sounded too good
if it's too dangerous for you marshalls
maybe i should go in
miss west miss wesson could you
i'm sorry about that thanks doris
anytime marshall kwon
thanks if you've got any feedback be
sure to fill out a form
we're going to talk to this chick over
here share daisy
especially i reckon you already heard
all about the dorsey red
so i won't bore you with the details
suffice it to say we whooped em good
and the survivors are holed up in the
garden of the gods thing is
when i suppose it doesn't fall for you
right my boys and girls are tired and
beat up
sorry you want it and by speak
you quan i hear you're some fancy
liaison now
old saul taking my people without even
asking
how dare he ma'am yes ma'am
and i'm glad to hear it yeah oh
multiplayer partners
from the fancy side of town 100 families
folk
try to get and please take young miss
wesson with you
i need that girl out of my head go in
there and kick some ass rangers
you gotta get this wes hmm i'm not sure
why the sheriff didn't assign me
marshalls
but well beggars as sheriff daisy told
you
they and some of our neighbors were
taken hostage by the dorseys
and i mean to free them all of them
so i'm ready when you are
i said before we talk about what you if
you could fight
certainly my father taught me to shoot
almost before i could walk
and i'm the best shot in the city i'm
the best shot in the city
the city man you may ask anyone
everyone knows what i can do oh god
but haven't you haven't killed it that's
nice
exactly hunted
there's no need to worry that i will be
shy about pulling the trigger
i promise strangers if it is to save my
family
i will not hesitate
all right all right let's just get her
at last
did i give you permission to like do
something with this
uh nothing came on my screen so which
one do you or these do you
you want give me her
[ __ ] pick right here okay yep there
you go
and you confirm
okay
strapped up like that come over here and
look at this nonsense
why they got those heads
come over here look at this how do i get
over there
should i help
[Music]
are you going back
rangers you told me that we were going
to save my family
this isn't the way to the garden of the
gods if you don't plan to honor your
word
i'm leaving
[Music]
family's taken hostage
they won't
don't get close to us what wouldn't be
market square without it
i heard we had some new arrivals wash on
sheriff said i should be expecting you
also said you'd have young lucia wesson
with you
she tells me you won't let her join you
it's the garden of the gods
experimental farms and now those [ __ ]
dorseys
nope no room for amateurs in this town
you hear sheriff said i should be
expecting you
we can't take the left you'd have young
lucia wesson with you
she tells me
rocks experimental farms and now there's
no room for amateurs in this town
you're here no because i'll pick lock
picking engine we can't get in there
no he's supposed to let us out jeff said
i should be expecting you
it's the guard it's the garden of the
gods
rocks experimental no roofer
alive and safe i ain't afraid to use
this gun martha
i ain't well yeah you're the worst
marksman here's market square the
arapahoe garage is just
outside the city gates god damn it doc
parker set up a clinic there
parker's the best doctor in town be a
hell of an asset if we can persuade him
to join the rangers
no room for amateurs prickly here
best no rule and these are just going to
leave areas
you just go here to leave all right
no we can yeah right now
this is where where stuff gets a little
little complicated
these people don't play matters
you can lose people
whoever just came up from the city come
in
this is
can you reach me with a ring just sit
tight we'll take care of the promises
stop being blubbering
with the rage sit tight we the rages
as dog as it's i thought we was
anti-dorsi
wait i thought we was yeah
oh no they found me
i don't know what that did okay
all right so we're gonna have to press
right
right on the down
you can actually that will let you move
characters individually
so right on the analog right bumper
where did you come from
back the hell off or you're dead
i guess we're fighting mm-hmm
[Music]
she can't even sleep
that's
hey damn [ __ ] just got real
all right
marshall's way the hell back here
this gonna be interesting
[Applause]
up all right we gotta get someone on
that ridge
well i got to get out of here
i expected more out of that flame though
right let me help you i'm gonna send my
homegirl over there they let it give me
products over there
she there ah [ __ ] her range ain't that
i'm gonna get a little closer half cover
those
good nah i don't want to get her yeah
she ain't a half cover situation
defend
three yeah i'm gonna risk it
unfortunately the ones near me is like
mad both hitting so i'm gonna hit this
one
at least they got off your bed she's
like a decoy for now
i don't want to die oh god we gotta help
out
damn let's switch weapons
[ __ ] oh the rocket launcher can do that
from this far oh but it's gonna kill her
oh but it's red okay
no targets in range all the rage is that
circle
okay got it got it got it yeah i can't
i gotta move a little closer to get him
though so what i'll do
is see if i can
yeah before
oh he had enough to attack oh
yeah so i got a switch oh it caused ap
to switch oh do i know okay
trouble all right so i'm just gonna
get him yeah
you're gonna have to fight her way out
she handled her business
she got one point
i [ __ ] her down yep
hmm peeled his head
oh oh god did the patriarch send you
i'm sorry i'm sorry i i need to warn you
the dorsis are gathering up ahead
between the gateway rocks
bellamy bellamy look at me have you seen
my family
are they here lucia uh
i thought you were with your family oh
thank god you're not
thank god they went up ahead with their
hostages but
lucio i heard gunfire and screaming
you need to be ready for the wall if
they've done anything to my people
i'm going to end them all
please do i'll tell whatever i can to
help
it's not much but
who are you and what are you doing here
the game has to just play
i think they took everyone to their camp
just past the gateway rocks
what about my family belle last i saw
them they were all right
they were scared and a little banged up
but
they were still alive
how do i heal her press x
twice
[Music]
what the hell just happened
oh she popped that out she was poisoned
or something
you should press x twice twice
i just see attack and i did press extra
oh
i'm not on her okay there we go that
hypo yeah my hypo
so you can't
wow
now when you lose individual for you
i haven't no got anything worthwhile
traps keep in mind detected yeah
so because of what skill were you able
to do that because i see them
supposed to move back right now what's
going on just
i don't think no one has repair unless
this dude's got a repair
my uncle tells me you're a man of
questionable
morals requires mechanics level two
that's why i'm on the payroll
somebody's gotta get their hands dirty
so good folks like you can keep your
hearts going
requires power
that's how you i'm sure you know best
all right what we're going to do is you
stay down here i'm going to oh no
follow me into this little fire thing we
have to fight anything in here
it's a creature in mind stop stop stop
i'm gonna shoot him and then we're gonna
start the fight
how do you start how do you initiate are
you going back
see if i can get all of them i wanna see
if i can get on
[Music]
oh i get to go again switch
out
but let's put this
well i probably need the more i can't
move away
all right just
yeah hey y'all got all the cover hey
don't come with me i'm not going all the
way up there
yeah that's the only thing that you
gonna do they gotta get
this person is blocking my path uh
all right let me switch
all right flame broil flame
broil
how many times you can go oh
we see it can get really good with that
demoralized
[Music]
you go ahead and just deal with this i
guess
can she shoot even though my partner's
in my face
oh come on
wow
he missed him be tight
you're gonna try for the show cuz he got
a sniper
damn not enough
you really like him
[Music]
range
the good thing about this is like
there's a red line shown when you're
close enough to shoot them
yeah that's it wow
really
yeah the flamethrower can't reach from
there right is it is the flame will the
flamethrower burn firmly
i think it will all right so i'm just
going to entertain
hopefully 68 chance
i'm gonna put myself on the watch
instead of doing this
all right so this is what we're gonna do
i'm a i'm gonna put my person my people
up here
and because i have the sniper now come
here
you're gonna take them from this side
so we'll flank them don't start it yet
though until i get my people
headed to archives all right
i started it
all right let's see
what i got animals blood beasts
don't target the range am i not are they
not here
it ain't not so
not what i'm gonna do
there we go
oh out of ammo
oh damn i might have messed that up oh
no it's still his turn
it's still gonna turn off oh it wouldn't
even let me do the ambush until i reload
okay how you do oh
and reload fully loaded all right so why
can't
ambush i i'm out of ammo to ambush even
though i have one in the chamber
i think ambush shoots multiple times
that's why
okay so we'll just switch okay
i'll and push
okay with her we gotta get her behind
this rod
ambush position
[Music]
uh
[Music]
start to get rough
he's faster yeah he making people
stronger
all right let's go
try to take care of those animals
oh no let's chase
oh he's out he's got to reload oh
i would just punch him down oh i could
use the special ability but i got no
bullets can i still use it i don't know
i will try it auto reload it
[Music]
but i don't know if it's gonna dotted
off ap
yeah that sucks i think it's like ready
yeah it's like ready for next turn
all right her she's gonna have to get
busy
we still got problems
all right
nice that helped now we just got this
piece to deal with
vipers in every xbomb game is always
open
for chief
that wasn't too bad i could take that oh
oh it's getting real
you might be a rap
oh man we got the beast next to us oh
it's
less words
entirely yeah i might be able to take
out the beast to be honest with you
i'm gonna use my super thing on the
beast
all right now let's talk and see if we
can get this little little guy out
come on what's up it's not killing
little things like this
i feel like we're changing that aren't
we
yeah right that flamethrower is
not it let's see what she do
we got to get this one dude out though
even though the beast is right
well you know what you probably shoot a
little dude i would kill them
shoot the big boy oh she got her joint
oh
she got her joint precision strike
charge up this big with each successful
attack target in the pacific area where
they want to flick special effects
oh yeah she got master all right i'm
gonna use this
this oh let's go body head legs
okay yeah we gotta get him out here
she got busy
now she killed me that's what i'm told
let's go
it's your first time shooting huh
she got a snapshot that's one ap useful
in combat
oh no targets in range oh she got a move
she can use when she got one eight one
ap
that's the first time i've ever seen
that
she hurt though she bleeding now oh i
supposed to hail her
[Music]
gonna be a problem
[Music]
uh
gotta watch out for this whoa thank you
all right now how do you heal uh x
twice oh she ain't got none
can a partner heal her
i think he got no i don't think we
haven't
it's fine we'll just try to shoot and
we're going to kill them long before
anything bad happens
there's only two left try to get that
one on the right because
i might have a hard time preaching yeah
the problem is
her ap so low but i'm gonna get her
out the way and i'm gonna put him
i might do it out
they won't die oh three ap for
yeah the big boy or should i do
to do in the back the sniper did you do
on the far right
sniper right yeah
yeah i like to buy for lunch
you ain't got about to be low but it is
good i give you a second
yeah i need to relocate this it probably
ain't gonna matter if i just get to
practice please
she gonna do that if you don't kill her
nice
she still bled out oh she still bleeds
out even after the turn
all right ended